I'm Jake and today we'll deliver
two-minute lightning pitches to a
roomful of Silicon Valley heavy hitters
with 100k on the line this is team
Technorati it's the moment of truth all
our hard work has led to this now we've
just got to control our stage fright
long enough to convince the judges our
projects are worth funding if the
tension backstage was electricity we
could light up the city I have two
minutes to share me and what I'd love to
do I remember someone that came up with
a solution to a prom it's always been
there
I have here a Snapdragon 800 processor
and I can honestly tell you that I don't
even scratch the surface of what this
device can do last year
I was scheduled to graduate but
unfortunately my lung literally exploded
I created Dogbot and I want to bring
computer aided physician diagnosis into
the clinical setting I'm Katherine Ray
and I'm going to fix everything that's
wrong with wheelchairs here's an
entirely separate set of actions that
will lead us down a path of prosperity
path of peace a path where we're
decreasing the tension it's a Korean
society neil armstrong's small step is
screaming for another giant leap Mars
could be our small step tyke is a small
robot which has an infrared temperature
sensor to go next to a body and find out
if it's dead or alive I want to make
education fun for everybody we've made
learning addicting with our platform
we've gained a 5 education come hit me
up to learn more we launched finish a
little bit over a year ago and we've
been blown away by our users response
and we're hugely honored to win the
Apple Design Award at last year's WWDC
almost everybody in this audience knows
at least one person they cared about
who's now dead from cancer I'm using
automated high-throughput drug screening
to analyze hundreds and thousands of
small molecules for drug hits that could
prevent cancer we um
I'm sure the TfL show can help me out
with this project
you so this is what bambina is it tracks
vital signs relays that information to
parents so that they're able to take
action and care for their child in an
innovative way thank you for all your
support I don't remember being on stage
and I don't know what I said so I guess
maybe I'll just have to watch a video
after because I really have no idea what
just but not affect if you want to come
see my prototype if you want to learn
more about what we're doing please come
talk to me thank you very much as soon
as I got that first sentence out it just
off seemed to fall into place I've never
done in speaking it all on upload
yourself like I did pretty much I am
passionate about improving the human
condition by using current technologies
to enable those in need thank you
although I did stumble once or twice and
I perhaps was more serious than I
intended to be just because I was trying
to get through it I think that I did
well I was expecting a couple more
laughs on those jokes but I guess this
isn't built laughing crowd gasps was 35
cents a gallon in a computer took up the
size of a reasonably priced apartment in
San Francisco tough crowd these tech
industry bigwigs and now we're about to
spend some quality time with them in the
mentor matches
I'm glad the pitches over if I'm really
excited about the medpar match because I
can't wait to show them like what I've
been working on the ideas I have and
just meeting people because these people
have done amazing things with their
lives and I have something to gain from
their experiences whose idea would you
invest a hundred can hit us up in the
comments and subscribe to the wire
channel for more teen Technorati
you